Rick mace who is a sports writer for The
Washington Post his recent column DJ
Durkin Maryland part ways following
outcry over coach's reinstatement Rick
kind enough to join us on short notice
Rick why was DJ Durkin fired well I mean
that's a good question I think it's what
everyone was going to ask in the past
couple the past 24 hours but I mean
basically there were there was a change
of heart and the backlash was so loud
and so so profound of so overwhelming
yesterday that the Maryland president
Wallace load decided that he needed to
kind of go with his heart and it's
important to understand why Laszlo
wanted to fire him initially but it's
the Board of Regents that kind of
oversee him and they're the ones that
urged him to bring DJ Durkin back there
was so much of an outcry yesterday but I
think Wallace LOH realized there's no
way DJ Durkin can continue coaching this
team and be on the sidelines Saturday
and he really had no choice he's though
but to finally reverse course and in
part ways with DJ Durkin but they
brought him back that that's what I like
that what happened in a 24-hour period
that you know aside from the reaction
he's not more guilty so it feels like
they fired him but they did did they
fire him for the correct reason well I
mean certainly many people think that
they could have made this move you know
in August or September but I think it's
important to realize there's two
different kind of entities two different
power brokers here there's a Board of
Regents and there's a university
president the university president felt
like his arm was twisted and he had no
choice but to follow the Regents
recommendation that I think the outcry
was so loud yesterday that he realized
that he had no choice but to defy that
recommendation and reverse course so
certainly he could to fight it from day
one but he was under the impression and
this is from from sources that we've
spoken to numerous times over the past
few days he was an impression that if he
didn't bring DJ Durkin back the board
would get rid of him and find someone as
someone else that would some other
president some other interim entity that
would follow their wishes
what's the accused of well they're not
firing him with cause they're not saying
that the program had toxic culture
they're not saying that he was in any
way responsible Jordan McNair his death
I think what they're technically they're
terminating his employment and you don't
need to really explain a reason because
of buying out his contract
so on a very simple level they're just
saying the relationship is not
sustainable DJ Durkin cannot continue as
head coach it's not the best thing for
the team for the university for the
campus community so there they don't
have to outline a specific reason or
give any cause because they don't feel
like they necessarily had cause to fire
him you know just on the spot and
terminate his employment you know what
they'll pay and you guys at the
Washington Post have done a great job
with this story over the last couple of
months but I'm curious with what you saw
with the actual work out where Jordan
McNair died like what what happened
there and who is anybody else culpable
for this aside from DJ Durkin well I
think there's so much finger-pointing
and there's been two investigative
reports and they've outlined a number of
bad actors here and so you know if youse
want to focus on that work out
specifically much of the focus of focus
has been on the athletic trainers who
who failed to diagnose him who failed to
that you know they didn't treat him
because they didn't properly diagnose
them and everyone you talk to would say
that the heatstroke is a very
preventable very curable thing if you
shoot them if you can realize the
temperatures too high get it back down
within an hour and then you know you
just carry on it's treated routinely on
college campuses and elsewhere so the
athletic trainers failed to failed to
diagnose Jordan and I think that we have
another story up this morning that we
just posted shortly before I came on
here another one of the Regents
recommendations that is somewhat
baffling is they urge College Park to
bring these two athletic trainers back
the two men that have been on leave in
connection with their their actions that
day and there's no explanation for why
they would do that a college Park has
not brought them back they still remain
on leave but it's just kind of baffling
to figure out why the Regents would
would make that kind of suggestion
lawsuits I think you're right that's a
plural I think you're gonna have
multiple lawsuits
they're gonna come from all directions
there certainly involves players
I don't expect DJ Durkin is gonna go
quietly if you wanted to walk away
quietly he would have negotiated a
buyout or settlement back in August or
September I think he had been ki feels
like he's been very much wronged here
I'm not sure a buyout is going to be
sufficient
he's gonna he's gonna feel like his
reputations damaged he's gonna feel like
his his long-term earnings have been
impacted here so you're going to have
multiple lawsuits and you know other
people other people are going to leave
there's gonna be other players that
speak up and certainly other players
that feel like they've been wronged and
I'm talking about multiple players
who've come through the program and they
feel like they're still suffering you
know PTSD type symptoms from for what
they experienced under DJ Durkin and
record the former strength and
conditioning coach so yeah there's no
shortage and I think plurals the the
right is the right way to say I'm going
to be a sports reporter some days but
probably a legal reporter and many more
days and the coming future I wondered if
it was gonna be a mess on Saturday that
you have a home game with Michigan State
and I I just wondered how what it what
the feel was gonna be like the fact that
DJ Durkin has been fired what do you
think was going to happen on Saturday
and with players if they were gonna play
the protest yeah I mean we'd heard that
some players we're talking about things
I think I never thought we were gonna
see a walkout our protest because one
thing you know when DJ Durkin was
allowed to return what is the message
that sends to the locker room err to
everybody it tells you that this guy is
untouchable you know there's there's no
reason to speak out because he's the one
that's going to survive everything and
so I just I just didn't have the sense
that players were gonna band together in
any kind of huge way even if some
individually were upset the DJ
tournament was back in place so I
certainly didn't think the 24 hours
later he was going to be fired I'm not
sure not sure anyone could have
predicted that things would happen that
quickly and I thought be really curious
to see what the vibe is of that stadium
on this Saturday weird from a ton of
alumni and fans that were embarrassed
for their school that were there were
sick over over this whole thing you know
not just Jordan McNair's death but the
way it's been handled and and treated or
you know ever since then so I'll be
curious if they come back or if they're
still disgusted and hurt over this
entire thing and feel like they need to
take a little break from from Maryland
football to be cleared
Marylyn football I mean the basketball
teams always been the you know the the
big show on campus the the program
sinaitic when I talk about Ohio State
here DJ Durkin was 10 and 15 you know in
his time
so it's always Santa always run a little
hot and cold on the football team
can you clear this up that there was a
sign-up sheet if you wanted to talk to
investigators and it was outside the
coach's office so like there's no
anonymity whatsoever and coach is gonna
be able to see who signs up is that is
that fact so I would have to dig back
into the report so I think you're
referring to the initial report that was
really focused more on the events
surrounding Jordan McNair's death yeah I
can tell you that the the second report
that was more on the culture of the
football program the day they spoke with
a lot more players players were provided
anonymity and I think the program was a
lot more helpful in that but I did so if
I remember correctly that first report
that was the initial way they tried to
reach out to players and I know a lot of
people inside the building took offense
but I do think there might have been
some measures taken after the fact to
maybe cast a broader net but I did
report did not have a lot of players in
it most most of the people that were
talked to for that report
we're trainers coaches people more and
more kind of official in nature
Thank You Ric for taking time we
appreciate it well done with the
Washington Post thank you anytime
that's Rick Macy's sports writer for The
Washington Post covering what happened
at Maryland for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]